alors nous allons évoquer quelques cas
particuliers du surprenant et puis
j'ajoute maintenant trois changements
d'affectation ségolène royal qui
quittent l'enseignement scolaire pour le
ministère à la famille à l'enfance
auprès de martine aubry dominique gillot
qui complète son secrétariat est récente
et en y ajoutant les handicapés enfin
marylise lebranchu qui concerne les
thèmes le commerce l'artisanat et
récupère la consommation auprès donc de
laurent fabius celui qui fut le plus
jeune premier ministre donné à la france
184 lorsque françois mitterrand le nomme
à matignon avait multiplié depuis
plusieurs mois ses interventions sur la
gestion économique
il semblait presque donner des conseils
en matière de baisses d'impôts de
retraite
laurent fabius devienne numéro deux du
gouvernement d'aucuns diront le vice
premier ministre tente il est apparu par
le passé comme un concurrent pour lionel
jospin commentaires jean baptiste preda
les héritiers de françois mitterrand
dauphin et frères ennemis lionel jospin
et laurent fabius partagent une longue
histoire une histoire parfois bien
mouvementée en 1980 à l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir
laurent fabius rejoint le gouvernement
lionel jospin lui et premier secrétaire
du parti socialise 1984 laurent fabius
remplace pierre mauroy à matignon
à 37 ans il est le plus jeune premier
ministre de la république
86e rang fabuleux conduire la campagne
des législatives
ce sera lionel jospin
l'affrontement culmine au congrès de
rennes en mars 90 des jours et des nuits
de déchirements à l'arrivée le divorce
consommé entre fabius et jospin
les héritiers sont devenus rivaux dans
les années 90 la sphère du sang
contaminé provoque l'effacement relatif
de laurent fabius cinq ans d'instruction
un procès devant la cour de justice
un acquittement marque 99 une blessure
depuis juin 97
laurent fabius a retrouvé la présidence
de l'assemblée nationale
un poste qu'il avait déjà occupé entre
88 et 92
mais depuis quelques temps à l'évidence
il rongeait son frein depuis l'été
surtout il a multiplié les avis je
concède que encore que les imposantes
rollo en france ce qui nuit à l'activité
économique et puis qui pèse énormément
sur durant toutes ces années dans
l'opposition comme dans la majorité
laurent fabius s'est voulu le leader
d'une gauche moderne et modernisatrice
son arrivée au gouvernement dix ans
après le congrès de rennes
ce n'est pas seulement la marque d'une
réconciliation désormais laurent fabius
devra se plier à la solidarité
gouvernementale